mais comme ça enflait sur les réseaux
sociaux ça enfle s en fait on était au
bout de quinze jours à 400 mille
messages entre twitter instagram
facebook et cetera à ce moment là on est
contacté par la police judiciaire parce
qu'au delà de 400 mille y pense qu'il a
une anomalie sur votre compte je monte
je la 990 1000 mais ça jusqu'à énorme
alors il ya au milieu de ses 900 ça
c'est celle que 990 mines faut sauver un
message de menace en 1948 le message
d'un sur un sept cent cinquante mille
insultes sur les 904 non 750 mille
messages de soutien ah oui de soutien et
150000 message d' insulte dont 130 et
une menace de mort c'est à dire qu'on
s'aperçoit qu'en fait il ya beaucoup de
gens qui ont compris dans la vie et qui
sont aussi sur les réseaux sociaux ce
que je voulais dire je comparerais deux
époques maladroitement certes mais je
comparais deux époques où on posait la
question des influences telles la
réussite enfin bref je peux pas revenir
sur ce dossier non je sais on va pas me
tuer mais il est vrai que moi voilà et
je vous le dis aussi c'est vrai que la
pauvre moi je crois que vous l'avez
essayé de la non mais je comprends
qu'elle ait pas vous parler parce que
elle a dû être extrêmement blessé et
c'est bon je vous dire le seul truc à
moi c'est cauchy et je le dis
franchement je la trouve extrêmement
mignonne mais c'est une grande chose
donc je pense qu'en fait je vous dire
encore ça aurait été vraiment quelqu'un
vraiment qui a un physique des compliqué
je pense serait temps corbillé mois au
moins aussi gelé vue elle est venue ici
elle est très belle et bien sûr jolie
fille vraiment je reviens sur l'aviation
et c'est vrai que géraldine tuer le truc
là comme selon c'est vrai que c'est une
sortie de route catastrophe ne soit vous
l'avez dit c'est un dérapage après vous
vous excusez et après en découle une
mise à mort médiatique c'est ça alors
nous ici on n'arrête pas de dire qu'on a
droit à une deuxième exactement que
quand on a payé sa peine c'est vrai la
cage et sa peine on a le droit à une
deuxième chance et l'a visiblement on
n'a pas droit à une deuxième c'est ce
que ces services est l'un des réseaux
sociaux c'est la pensée horizontale
comme aux états unis c'est à dire c'est
des gens qui nous disent toute la
journée que le feu ça brûle et l'eau ça
mouille c'est ça les réseaux sociaux
donc toute une bien pensants se met
derrière ça et d'un seul coup on est là
alors on se dit mais attendez j'ai tué
personne je suis pas un violeur
peintures d'enfants je suis pas pardonné
mais il a quand même convient pas à
l'époque ont fait part dont vous êtes là
vous avez la gueule qui ne convient pas
à l'époque que tu me conduit c'est
presque un elissalde gueule exalead mois
à venir et la voyez si vous avez raison
vous être blanc vous avez plus de 50 ans
vous êtes hétéro
mais bien sûr là bas mais je suis
d'accord l'argent moi au départ les une
sortie de route et
je vais vous dire gérald et une personne
est à l'abri sur un mois ce qui me
chagrine sincèrement je prends la parole
c'est qu'on est en train de devoir avoir
de la peine pour l'attaquant et moi ça
me fait chier clairement parce qu'à un
moment donné là c'est quand même toi
l'attaquant fabien c'est toi qui as
attaquant volontairement
involontairement mais quand même ça t'es
pas débile takam dit des mots je te
remercie laisser des mots très forts et
c'est vrai moi je verrais bien tous les
deux ah oui moi je les adore ça a été
mon nom
mon voisin pendant des mois et des
années au dos on s'adore mais moi ce qui
me fâche c'est que là on peut pas te
plaindre parce que tu as atteint qu'une
personne ces jeux de vente pas être sur
son physique non mais je demande pas je
demande parce qu'on me comprenne
maintenant j'aurais aimé ce que j'aurais
simplement aimé c'est qu'en fait je suis
là contact et tu fasse tout pour essayer
de la joindre et que tu t'excuses devant
elle parce qu'en fait tu te situes en
utilisant encore les réseaux pour
t'excuser se dire qu'on tourne en rond
j'espère que c'est que les réseaux les
réseaux les réseaux et après la saison
il ya un drame et moi je n'utilise pas
les réseaux pour merci parce que tu
t'excuses publiquement sur les réseaux
mais non non non non ça fait ressortir
des réseaux il faut se mettre dans la
vraie vie et s'excuser dans la vraie vie
ça se passe que les gars la vraie vie
c'est ce qui coûte le plus mais alors je
vais te laisser les gens votent il sait
parler à lorient si les gens refusent il
ya parce que dans tout ça ça a été
instrumentalisée quand même j'sais pas
si vous en êtes où se persuade mais ce
que vous avez essayé de la contacter non
bon alors parce que la morquenne sinon
j'ai appelé j'ai appelé son attaché de
presse que je connais bien par ailleurs
sa manager apparemment c'est aussi sa
compagne dans la vie et apparemment il y
avait un espèce de blocus non on veut
surtout pas parler bon d'après
ok de fleurs avec un petit mot pour dire
mais donnez-moi son adresse face à
santés
après après la laddh alors oui enfin on
parle aussi sur le fond mais sur la
forme ça légitime pas les menaces de
mort non plus
on